c'est une information pour le moins
insolite que révèle le journal le canard
enchaîné aujourd'hui chela au casting
d'une pub pour les vaccins et pas
n'importe quel vaccin celui
d'astrazeneca qui a vu sa cote de
popularité tombée en flèche au vu des
différents effets secondaires qu'il
procurait est effectivement dans ce pays
des rapports de cas graves de caillou
souvenir chez des personnes vaccinées
par ce vaccin
jean castex qui avait déjà essayé de
rassurer les français en se faisant
vacciner a trouvé une idée plus
judicieuse tourner des clips
publicitaires avec des stars de plus de
55 ans pour promouvoir le fameux
antidote et sa décision se serait arrêté
sur celle a alors la chanteuse accepte
un tel la mission à 1 est moins sûr
[Applaudissements]
au début on est venu ici je crois extime
vad je vous jure que je suis comme vous
comme le piquage ballerines ou feu non
c'est pas une balle un je vous le dis
c'est pas une vanne voilà mais je vous
dis il rabat robot maltings avec son
show fallen idol et gauloises d'ailleurs
là ils sont là ils sont sur le dossier
là là là ils sont comme ça là dix mois
en actifs surplus au carré là bas et on
active dans les mecs pour atol les
opticiens castaldi blé c'est
complètement inutile ce genre
d'opération qui on veut convaincre et
que ça les anti vaccins qui pensent que
les médias et le système nous mentent en
général or les stars font partie du
système donc si one star qui se fait
vacciner ça va les convaincre de
vacciner il a demandé à china parce
qu'il adore chez la ban de chennai les
fans des rois mages en galilée donc il a
le look mais après après que j'adore
chez la jeune fille mais sauf qu'elle a
75 ans donc déjà astrazeneca
c'est pour les 75 ans et c'est pas
dangereux en a 75 ans traduit mais on y
va enfin c'est elle et peut-être même
déjà vaccinées chela je voulais que les
vaccins astrazeneca plus de 55 ans
moderna entre 53 et 57 either entre 80
et 100 lisse et voilà et bien entendu le
thiès de 7 à 77 ans voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on pourrait ensuite on va payer une
campagne de communication pour un accent
d'un laboratoire privé
bah oui oui quant à eux et moi je pense
que si on doit vraiment convaincre les
gens il faut montrer des gens qui
travaillent qui sont malades dans la
plateforme de l'âge des gens de 50 ans
il faudrait que didier deschamps zidane
carla bruni des gens comme ça et ça
c'est ainsi très beaucoup plus les gens
espèrent je pense vous êtes fait
vacciner vos castaldi attendait car oui
c'est les yeux ça
[Applaudissements]
mais malheureusement vous avez les yeux
qui se ferme petit article
en revanche je n'aurai pas la deuxième
dose non mais si je peux vous donner un
conseil ne la fait pas vous êtes déjà
attaqué comme çà c'est vrai ça va
dégonfler encore la wii voilà on est là
on est à 25 %
c'est vrai deux des conflits tude ouais
ouais d'accord ça va bien merci
ça fait ressortir votre route lâcheté
famille et m'a dit eh oui vous êtes n'a
pas aujourd'hui avec je vous adore me
fait toujours sentir il est passé quoi
je m'inquiète pour vous et je voyais
beaucoup de tweets de gens qui disent
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait badji à ses yeux
ou pourquoi est ce qu'ils disent à votre
avis non non c'était le temps dans votre
émission est pas là c'est pas vous qui
aimez danser phrase a dû tout à dieu
vous venez pour rien bien sûr c'est à
dire tu sais ce que tu te mettes un
miroir c'est pas moi non mais frérot ça
va très bien je sais que ça va dégonfler
mais pour l'instant c'est un peu chelou
on dirait que tu as des lentilles sans
rigoler des lentilles mains des nantis
mais des lentilles à manger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mon but c'est de montrer qu'il a la rage
dans les yeux oui moi je trouve que
c'est très bien chez l'homme celle là
est une vraie star pour les plus doués
pour les plus de 50 ans et il faut un
modèle on a tous besoin d'un modèle
d'ailleurs c'est pas la seule vraiment
que alors j'ai rien contre eux dh qui
fait avec croyais que si celle a dit
ouais comme et on va manger en galets
toi aussi bien te faire vacciner
vive l'été arrive
l'escale à l'échelle chéri robert koch
encore vaccinés comme et rois mages en
cabinet oui mais c'est quand tu prends
l'avion
[Applaudissements]
j'adore et non pas que ça aurait donné
ça serait magnifique
oui qu'est ce qui se passe c'est dingue
ce qui est des steevy cela pouvait
infléchir l'opinion des villes peu chez
la star aux yeux si oui alors oui quoi
mais non le champ ci par là nous saurons
nous convainc qu'on n'a pas besoin d'un
gadget comme celle après celle à lâcher
la campagne de pub est un gadget si tu
vas par là même sur certains tweets 51,6
avait pas de bien ça fait pas de mal
honnêtement c'est peut être ça peut en
amuser certains là honnêtement je suis
comme stevie je trouve que cette année
qui perd t elle un homme et sa porte en
haut j'avais des difficultés au niveau
des sondages